nos piden que resolvamos para james el
valor absoluto de más 22 esto tiene que
ser menor o igual que 13.5 así que lo
primero que voy a hacer es lo mismo que
he hecho en todos los vídeos anteriores
lo primero que voy a hacer es tratar de
dejar al valor absoluto de y de un lado
de esta desigualdad y para eso es lo que
me estorba es este 22 por lo tanto voy a
restar 22 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad menos 22 menos 22 muy bien y
primero aquí estos dos se van entonces
solamente me queda el valor absoluto de
james esto tiene que ser menor o igual
que 13 puntos 5 menos 22 pero cuántos
13.5 menos 22 13.5 menos 22 bueno esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
menos menos ya por paréntesis y voy a
poner 13.5 en negativo más 22 o dicho
otra manera 22 menos 13.5 al final lo
que estoy haciendo es multiplicando por
menos y 22 menos 3.5 esto es lo mismo
que en 13.5 para 20 es 6.52 esto es 8.5
esto de aquí es 8.5
pero cuando lo multiplicó por menos me
queda menos 8
punto 5 entonces me quedan que el valor
absoluto de ella tiene que ser menor que
menos 8.5 y justo en este momento es
cuando algo debe decir en tu cabeza que
está mal algo empieza a funcionar muy
extraño por aquí porque si nosotros
tomamos el valor absoluto de cualquier
número que sea de cualquier número que
sea éste es mayor o igual a cero es
decir que no hay ningún valor absoluto
que mete en negativo nosotros tomamos el
valor absoluto de a esto igual a x x
tiene que ser un número positivo o de
otra manera x tiene que ser no negativo
porque no hay ningún valor absoluto que
sea negativo si yo por ejemplo me tomo
el valor absoluto de menos 3 este estrés
positivo si me tomo el valor absoluto de
3 de resultado obtendría 3 sin tomar
valor absoluto de 0 pues es 0 es decir
que no hay ningún número cuyo valor
absoluto sea negativo y si esto lo
traducimos lo que está pasando aquí lo
que me está diciendo esta desigualdad es
que el valor absoluto de ya tiene que
ser menor o igual que menos 8.5 pero
todos los números que sean menores que
menos 8.5 van a ser negativos entonces
lo que me está diciendo esta desigualdad
es que el valor absoluto
tiene que ser negativo y esto no tiene
nada de sentido justo por lo que
acabamos de ver cualquier número que nos
tomemos en valor absoluto va a ser mayor
o igual que 0 por lo tanto si yo lo que
quiero es que el valor absoluto y que
sea menor o igual que menos 8.5 esto me
lleva a una contradicción o dicho de
otra manera si yo lo que quiero es
obtener la solución de esta desigualdad
que tengo aquí pues la respuesta es que
no existe ninguna solución